the President of the United States is in
some hot water with HBO in conjunction
with Attorney General Bill Bars press
conference discussing the release of the
redacted Muller report Donald Trump took
to Twitter with a game of Thrones
inspired image that quickly drew the ire
of the cable channel it's overlaid text
in a very Thrones like font reads no
collusion no obstruction for the haters
and the radical left Democrats game over
game of Thrones fever is at an all-time
high at the moment with the first
episode of the venerable series final
season having just aired as deadline
reports HBO slyly referenced this fact
in a statement following the president's
tweet though we can understand the
enthusiasm for Game of Thrones now that
the final season has arrived
we still prefer our intellectual
property not be used for political
purposes this is hardly the first time
Trump's gotten blowback for co-opting
intellectual property to make a
political statement in fact it's not
even the first time he's used Game of
Thrones to do so last November he
tweeted an image of himself with the
text sanctions are coming again the
slogan was rendered in a terribly
familiar font and again it prompted an
epic response from HBO's official
Twitter account how do you say trademark
misuse in Dothraki
that unmistakeably snarky comeback
didn't keep Trump from basically pulling
the same shenanigans in January of this
year he posted another image that owed
its aesthetic to Game of Thrones along
with the caption the wall is coming
following the November incident HBO
released a statement saying they weren't
aware of the messaging but didn't
approve of it nevertheless the network's
spokesperson jeff cuss on implied that
no legal action would be taken at the
end of the day the case could be made
that Trump's tweets are parody which is
protected under the Fair Use Act even or
perhaps especially if the tweets are
coming from someone who occupies the
highest office in all the land
apparently the president's legal team is
only vaguely aware of the subtleties
involved in copyright law after all it's
been barely a week since another Trump
tweet misappropriated intellectual
property and that tweet wound up being
removed on April 9th the president
posted a video hyping his 20/20
reelection campaign it just so happened
to be scored too why do we fall a
classical
by hans zimmer composed for the 2012
superhero flick The Dark Knight Rises
the video incorporated text rendered in
a font that was suspiciously similar to
those in the film's credits Warner
Brothers the studio behind the Dark
Knight trilogy quickly responded with a
curt statement of their own the use of
Warner Brothers score from The Dark
Knight Rises in the campaign video was
unauthorized we are working through the
appropriate legal channels to have it
removed parody is one thing but as any
rapper will tell you you can't just jack
other people's tunes for your own
purposes unless you want to end up in
court while HBO may not have a case for
trademark infringement some legal
analysts believed they could argue that
the president's usage of Game of Thrones
imagery constituted trademark dilution
an entirely separate concept anyway it's
hard to imagine any Game of Thrones fan
thinking the image was proof positive of
HBO and the show's cast and crew
endorsing the president's opinion of the
Moller report we're not in the business
of taking political stances here at
looper but we are in the business of
taking a stance on Game of Thrones
with that in mind we'd like to point out
that the president's tweet doesn't make
much sense in the context of the series
unless we missed a crucial episode we're
pretty sure there aren't any Democrats
in Westeros we suppose there are plenty
of haters on the show though perhaps not
in the way Trump meant
regardless there's no argument that the
series will be coming to a close at the
end of May so indeed the game is nearly
over well like the old adage says two
out of three ain't that or is it
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
Game of Thrones are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell C you don't miss a single one
[Music]